I know that you're a busy guy yes and 5u
I really do have to go you got to go
yeah I have this meeting I'm not
supposed to talk about by the meeting
first show that could really change my
life and keep me off the road yeah I
could spend more time with my son
okay eleven-year-old and I just want to
spend more time with because time is
going by so fast and this will keep me
off the road and and I'll come back and
talk about it when if the meeting works
out great
well this is I'm excited this meeting
works out for thank you and I was like
okay that's okay you know what we love
you Kevin
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that is so nice this has never happened
to me before but that is the nicest I
told you I had a connection with this
audience that's energy but the truth is
I do have to go to this meeting and but
I but I you know I I just want you to
know that I do appreciate the love and I
do feel it and thank you for coming to
the show today because I was on it and
you guys are the back alright alright
thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
but here's the thing I I'm a real I'm a
people-pleaser and I hate to leave
because I feel guilty because they came
to see me and I feel a connection and I
feel the love and so I don't want to
leave but I have to go because I you
know coz then I want to spend more time
with my child you understand and this
meeting is important to me you get to it
yeah so again thank you very much and I
appreciate thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I said I have a meeting to go to
it's important otherwise I'm not going
to spend time with my son but apparently
that's not important to you I thought we
had something here I thought we had some
kind of a synergy a chemistry thing here
but now I see a side of you that I
didn't see before and it's an ugly side
of you and in it and it's disappointing
I can't make you happy for the rest of
your life happiness counselor no I am
embarrassed for you and I'm gonna shame
for you I never saw this side of you
before it I'm glad I saw this before it
went any further I'm really disappointed
find something else to do
Conan it can be entertaining at times
watch now
enjoy he's got more guests on but don't
put the pressure on me I'm sorry it's
ending this way
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
no no means no and oh I am this close to
calling my lawyer
and it's not Michael Cohen and there
will be individual lawsuits throughout
this studio so help me God I mean this
is really embarrassing for you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you guys were not helping there it's
called enabling
you